so people can't afford to buy a house
people don't want to sell their house
they'd rather Airbnb it or lease it
means the supply Supply is down and
demand is down so on the residential
Market I believe you know the FED is
saying it's probably going to be two
years to the end of 25 till we have um
Federal interest rates back down to
three and they're probably looking to
raise in July because there's been some
statistics out that say that the economy
is still a little too hot and there's
still a little too much inflation things
are tough so there you have it folks
that's why I believe for the next two
years certain parts of the housing
market May shift most markets I think
are just going to be there's a new
status quo on the number of houses that
are selling and prices are not going to
drop through the floorboards